[Musique]
80000 personnes sur huit jours
d'événements le bonheur des enfants au
jardin de l'état encore une fois
rencontré un franc succès ce bonheur des
enfants a été très difficile à démarrer
puisque vous avez plus le temps de
réfléchir
qu'est ce que nous allons faire cette
année avec les paramètres de jours de
vacances puisque les vacances démarrent
et que le 23 et finalement ce bonheur
des enfants comme tous les ans depuis
six ans a été magique et là on est on
est bluffé
on est bluffé par le résultat qu'a fait
le travail de tous les agents et
franchement moi je dis juste merci à
tous merci beaucoup
les nombreux ateliers animations fait le
bonheur de tous certains ne sont pas
venus qu'une seule fois
plusieurs nids des bixi aux verts belle
ici l'atelier jeu moi j'ai bien aimé
l'épaule
or après le stage autres il s est aussi
heureux de ma vie
le département souhaitait clôturer cette
édition du bonheur des enfants avec un
spectacle grandiose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]